la machine à remonter le temps va
redémarrer et stella matutina de nouveau
brillé dans la constellation des musées
régionaux c'est tant mieux aussi pour
les personnels
un patient eux aussi après plus de deux
mois d'arrêt ah bah c'est une bonne
nouvelle on avait besoin de retrouver le
public et va s'évertuer à m le visiteur
dans twitter meilleures conditions
bohrer pour la visite et et amuser sans
moon de danse et un case vide tout le
protocole de déconfinement appliquée au
musée a été respectée depuis la
billetterie jusqu'au déplacement à
l'intérieur de cette structure de 6000
m² pouvant d'ordinaire accueillir
jusqu'à 500 personnes à la fois là ce ne
sera pas plus de soixante dix en même
temps nous avons prévu d'en accueillir
dix personnes environ dans chaque espace
est donc ses visiteurs doivent respecter
un sens de visite que nous avons mis en
place en essayant bien sûr de proposer
un circuit de visite qu'ils soient
toujours attractif et où le visiteur
pourra bien entendu voir l'essentiel
mais certaines zones exiguës ne pouvant
éviter les croisements entre visiteurs
ne seront pas accessibles
c'est le cas du quart courants d'air
habituellement vrai point d'attraction
c'est un peu un crève coeur mais on n'a
pas trop le soir et les mesures en vidéo
une cinquantaine d'agents assurer le
fonctionnement du musée avant la crise
qu vide
ils seront douze en même temps sur le
site le temps de travail a été réaménagé
pour limiter les risques
du coup on nous prend deux techniciens
en début de semaine et enfin et deux
autres techniciens au milieu de semaine
pour éviter les contacts stella matutina
connaît la troisième plus forte
fréquentation des musées régionaux après
kélonia et la cité du volcan avant le
coc vide son public était composé à 60%
de touristes extérieurs
aujourd'hui il faut encore plus séduire
le locaux la direction a choisi
d'appliquer pour cela le tarif réduit
kélonia donc pratiquera donc le tarif à
5 euros dont son tarif réduit stella
matutina donc 6 euros la cité du volcan
6 euros et le mas doit 2 euros
alors ce tarif donc sera pratiquée
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'août et pour
les enfants de moins de 12 ans dans tous
les musées l'accès à l'histoire et
gratuit le visiteur devra aussi porter
un masque